happy Valentine's Day lovely people I
don't know about you but I am single for
the second valentine's day in a row be
sure to hit that subscribe button to
find out if i'll go three-for-three next
year but for now let's do gaming news
first up a DLC pass is coming for the
legend of zelda breath of the wild the
twenty dollar expansion path includes
two sets off downloadable content plus
some instant extras that you can get
your hands on as soon as the game comes
out these consist of three new treasure
chests that will pop up in breadth of
the wilds great plateau area Nintendo
said one of these treasure chests will
contain a shirt with a Nintendo switch
logo that link can wear during his
adventure exclusive to the expansion
pass the other two will deliver useful
items as for the other content packs the
first will be out this summer and
includes the cave of trials challenge a
hard mode and a new feature for the
in-game map the second DLC pack which is
set to arrive in the holiday season of
this year includes new challenges that
will let players enjoy a new dungeon and
a new original story the content packs
will be available on both switch and we
use next up the second DLC pack for
resident evil 7 is out today on ps4 the
band footage volume 2 pack includes two
scenarios and a new mode called jacks
55th birthday the first scenario 21 will
have you quote gambling life and limb in
a deadly game run by Lucas Baker the
second scenario called daughters acts as
a prequel to the main game if you need a
break from all the tents claustrophobic
hallways and inventory management Jack's
55th birthday is described as a comical
mode that will see you feeding the
game's villain tons of food and footage
volume 2 is a timed exclusive on ps4 and
will be out on Xbox one and PC on the
twenty-first of February's finally
Bioware has stressed that Mass Effect
Andromeda will not be an open-world game
producer Michael gamble told official
Xbox Magazine I definitely wouldn't call
Andromeda an open-world game we like to
use the term exploration based game you
still have the concept of tight story
deliverance and all the great things you
come to it
backed with mass effect adding the layer
on top of that is a layer of exploration
sometimes that happens in open spaces
but not always you can cruise around
some of these planets in the nomad but
it's not the traditional sandbox tight
game the Nomad is of course the new mako
which hopefully in no way resembles the
Mako at least not in terms of handling
new Andromeda screenshots arrived today
so be sure to check those out on games
but that is everything I've got for you
today do leave me your thoughts in that
comment section head to gamespot for all
our coverage of fauna which came out
today and i will see you again tomorrow